la reconnaissance faciale fait déjà
partie de notre quotidien elle lui sert
par exemple à déverrouiller l'écran de
nos téléphones portables est dorénavant
à moscou cette technologie permet
également de payer ce titre de transport
il s'agit tout d'abord de la sécurité du
passager il ne touche rien il utilise
seulement son visage pour payer son
billet
c'est la première chose deuxièmement
cela nous permet de réduire les files
d'attentes au cours des dix dernières
années nous avons commencé à introduire
de nouvelles options pour payer les
titres de transport notamment par cartes
bancaires et portables et nous avons
constaté que les files d'attentes
s'étaient réduites de 3 fois
nous espérons que l'introduction de
faith paix y aura le même effet le
passager n'ayant pas à chercher son
portable ou sa carte bancaire
la procédure prend le même temps qu'un
paiement par carte bancaire
j'aime bien les nouvelles technologies
et je suis tout de l'intelligence
artificielle aux cryptes aux monnaies il
me semble que l'avenir appartient de
telles technologies
donc lorsque le département des
transports de moscou a proposé de
participer à des tests du service
facebook dans le métro j'ai dit oui
c'est génial
sur l'ensemble des deux cent quarante et
une station du réseau il sera désormais
possible de circuler sans sa carte
bancaire ou sans la troïka la carte du
réseau de transports en commun de
l'agglomération de moscou les autres
moyens de paiement reste bien entendu
disponibles certaines voix s'élèvent
néanmoins contre l'utilisation massive
de la reconnaissance faciale et les
risques de dérives et de fuites de
données que cela peut engendrer
je crois que j'ai quelques doutes à ce
sujet
quels sont vos doutes exactement de quoi
avez vous peur
peut-être qu elles tomberont entre de
mauvaises mains
vous utiliserez quand même le nouveau
système ou non à vrai dire non je ferai
comme d'habitude j'utiliserai des
billets classiques
l'aspect pratique c'est une chose la
sécurité des données en est une autre
quelles questions vous posez vous en ce
qui concerne la sécurité des données ce
n'est pas une très bonne chose et
d'après la régie de transports
nous protégeons toutes les données
personnelles des passagers les
coordonnées bancaires utilisées pour le
paiement sont stockées par la banque
nous n'avons rien à voir avec ces
informations mais les photographies que
les passagers télécharge sur
l'application pour s'inscrire et
utiliser le service ne sont plus stockés
comme des photographies mais comme des
clés biométrique
comment fonctionne ce système lorsqu'un
passager télécharge sa photo sur
l'application elle la transforme en clé
biométrique puis le passage et
s'approche du portail regarde la caméra
et celle ci traite les données du
passager
le métro moscovite a toujours été à la
pointe des nouvelles technologies
il a été dans les premiers à proposer le
wifi sur l'ensemble de son réseau les
rames les plus récents disposent des
ports usb entre chaque siège et c'est
dorénavant le moyen de paiement qui fait
sa petite révolution